okay so i have not made a news roundup
video in
forever i don't know i've ever done it
on this channel um which means the fact
that i'm making this means i'm very
interested in a lot of the stuff
that's happened this week it ended up
being
kind of a wild week for gaming news and
there was just some stuff that i wanted
to talk about so the first thing in case
you missed it is that uh if i pull over
this ign article
right here e3 2022 digital and physical
have officially been canceled the esa
has confirmed
the cancellation um
i did already know this one i actually
said it
on a q a recently forgetting that it
wasn't public um
so i kind of linked it somebody in the
comments corrected me and was like
actually e3 is still a thing and i was
like oh my bad
um
so the article says after previously
cancelling its in-person e3 2022 event
the esa has now informed its partners
that there will be no digital event
equivalent this year either meaning e3
2022 has fully been cancelled
the news broke via a tweet from razer pr
lead will powers which is a wild way
something like this to come out who said
that an email uh
i feel like i should give context that i
know will powers quite well and i'm not
surprised he specifically was the one
who did this um
who said that an email had been sent out
announcing the cancellation of a digital
e3 event ign has independently verified
the contents of the email as well so
basically it seems like the esa just
sent out an email and told everybody
no e3 which is seems like such a strange
way to approach this but i don't know
how the events side of the games
industry works in that capacity like i
don't know if that means people had to
cancel their events
i doubt it
uh the esa had initially planned for an
in-person e3 event this year after
having no event in 2022 to covet and a
digital one in 2021 however this was
cancelled in january with the esa at the
time unable to make a public statement
on whether or not there would be a
digital equivalent according to sources
speaking ign at the time discussions
around e3 have been fraught throughout
the year with third parties normally
involved in finding the esa's ongoing
silence regarding their plans
frustrating
this is part of this that i find
particularly interesting um
the esa shared an official statement
with ign confirming e3's 2022
cancellation and announcing that e3 will
return in 2023 with a reinvigorated
showcase
from what i have heard
this is nonsense um it seems like they
were trying to do a possible digital
event this year and couldn't get it
together
and
basically pivoted
realizing that this year wouldn't work
to doing it next year instead and like
trying to re-pick up that steam
what i suspect is going to happen
again just from what i've heard and not
heard anything from the esa i've just
heard things from friends who like work
at publishers um so i can't verify that
any of this is correct i have not had
any conversation with the esa second
hand source is what i'm trying to say
um
the esa plans to do a digital event
this year
didn't know if they could put it
together realized they couldn't and then
pushed to next year instead um
but that happened last minute so my
guess is that potentially there will be
some kind of digital thing
next year
but the entire industry is making plans
separately from e3 at this point so
uh the entire rest of the industry
is going ahead uh with making their own
showcases or joining other people's
showcases like obviously uh jeff
keeley's doing
summer game fest i think it's called
maybe that's the ign one i don't
remember
summer game
thing
um
and from what i've heard about that it
sounds like there will be an in-person
component uh that will have something
kind of similar to
judges week
um
which a lot of the public probably
didn't really know about but it's
basically just a lot of
games media used to be able to uh head
down to e3 a little bit early and play
some of the games that would otherwise
be on the show floor so
in any case what i think is actually
going to happen here despite this quote
which i should read where the esa said
we will devote all our energy and
resources to delivering a revitalized
physical and digital e3 experience next
summer whether enjoyed from the show
floor or your favorite devices the 2023
showcase will bring the community media
and industry back together
in an all-new format and interactive
experience we look forward to presenting
e3 to fans around the world live from
los angeles in 2023
i don't doubt that they have every
intention of doing that and then it
probably will happen
um but i don't think they're likely to
get a tremendous amount of publisher
support when so many publishers have
realized that they can just do their own
thing separately um with a lot more
focus on just their games
obviously ea has been doing that for a
while with ea play even in person in la
very effectively
doesn't mean you require your audience
to have to go through the halls and see
every other competitor's game there as
well
i don't think there's a place for e3
anymore and it's a blessing and a curse
um they doxed me
they've had organizational problems for
a while
however
i feel like
looking back e3 was probably a part of
why i got so involved in the industry
uh from a young age was you know i was
having to wake up at 3am in australia to
watch e3 livestreams it was like
it's like christmas for gamers you know
like it was just so exciting every year
having that week of the biggest
announcements all at once was was very
very like
thrilling and it's already kind of
tapered out now things spread out and
even when i was like working in ign
reporting on e3 live in person things
are spreading out further and further
and further and a day or a week was
getting added to e3 it was becoming
bigger and bigger and bigger um as
people were trying to like separate from
each other's announcements
so
it's been happening for a while
i do think it's a really big bummer
i always said to myself you know there
are some people who work in
facets of the games industry who hate e3
who have all these tweets about how much
e3 sucks how tired they are
and i always said if i ever become one
of those people i should leave the
industry if i ever stop being excited
about e3
i should give my position away to
somebody else um
because i loved it so much
even the working e3 as media at ign was
exhausting like
so physically painful
from all of the just
ah
tireless hours
of walking that show floor um
yeah my feet would kill me by the end of
the week and you get no sleep and you
get sick and you just burnt out but
there's such a high from it that
i'm sad to see it go um it's one of my
favorite parts of the year every year so
definitely sad to see it go
but i do think that there's benefit to
publishers being able to choose how they
want to do their showcases themselves
independently of e3 and have more
control over the time and potentially
have more fan facing
um events i don't love them all being
spread out but
we've been saying that the e3 was dying
for ages and this this does feel
a bit like the final nail in the coffin
um i don't doubt that they will do
something next year but again from all
the conversations i've had it seems like
there's very little publisher interest
people are going to either create their
own events or go with the ign summer
event or jeff keeley's summer event or i
think kind of funny had done like an
indie showcase before um
there's just so many
more efficient focused ways to
market now and it's almost like for a
smaller game
for your double a why would you want to
be a part of e3 you'd want to be in your
own week or your own day entirely so
it's it's a bummer for new people
joining the industry
um
i think it was coming for a while it's
so expensive to do those events and it's
kind of not efficient so that was the
first piece of news the next one is a
remedy
very excited about this
remedy remaking
max
payne
here's the article remedy and rockstar
games announced max payne 1 and 2 remake
for pc ps5 xbox
series x hi gnaws
uh remedy and rockstar games have
announced that they will be remaking max
payne and max payne to the fall of max
payne in a surprise announcement remedy
will work with rockstar under a new
publishing agreement to remake the first
two max payne games for pc playstation 5
and xbox series x and s remedy will
handle development while rockstar will
finance the project which will be in
line with typical remedy aaa game
production the max payne remakes will
also be developed on remedy's northlight
game engine the same engine used to
develop control and the upcoming allen
way 2 which i think looks very good oh
me need to seize
uh the original max payne games were
also a result of a partnership between
remedy and rockstar with remedy handling
development and rockstar games
publishing rockstar also handled the
development of max payne 3 which
i think max payne 3 is underrated um
to be clear
it's the least interesting of the max
payne games
but i still don't think it gets the
credit it deserves max payne 3 was
really fun time i also just love max
payne i have like such a soft spot
for that grouchy old addict i love him
um quote here from
rockstar founder sam hauser says we were
thrilled when our longtime friends at
remedy approached us about remaking the
original max payne games we are massive
fans of the work remedy the remedy team
has created over the years and we can't
wait to play these new versions and then
a remedy ceo said max payne has always
held a special plate in the hearts of
everyone at remedy and we know the
millions of fans worldwide feel the same
remedy is working on a lot of stuff i
think they're doing
one of the campaigns
for crossfire they're obviously working
on
alan wake right now
um alan wake too that is which is super
exciting
control they have they have just a
really interesting portfolio i love
remedy i love the way they write um
the remedy ceo added the team is excited
to bring the story action and atmosphere
of the original max payne games to
players in new ways
i'm super excited um love max payne
stoked to play them again
sign me up the thing i wanted to mention
is some people
flagged concerns with rockstars
association so
i i do love rockstar and i think i've
said it on the channel before if i were
to work for any studio other than sony
santa monica who obviously i'm currently
writing for
it would be rockstar there would be the
other studio that i would go right for i
can't even imagine it seems like it
would be incredible
they got a lot of criticism rightfully
for
the gta trilogy um i'm saying the
criticism is rightfully but it was
directed to the wrong place so that that
gta trilogy re-release
was not actually
made by rockstar um it's obviously a
rock star title but it was not made by
rockstar and rockstar are in an
interesting position where
they have things that i don't
like about them
but i would not blame rockstar itself
for any of their issues
um
they are published by take two owned by
take two
uh take two interactive who also own 2k
a bunch of studios and
rockstar are in this interesting
position where
almost guaranteed no matter what they
are always going to release the most
expensive game ever made
every time
when they come out with red dead
redemption 2 when they come out with gta
6 which of course has single player
story currently in development of course
it does they announced it but it was so
weird to me that people thought that
um that wasn't being made at all
i mean i think i've made jokes about it
but there's no way that they weren't
going to do that
um
for you to be able to finance these huge
very expensive games that rockstar makes
that are
almost in a league of their own in terms
of just like spectacle and scale and
like the things that they push um for
the industry you have to make a lot of
money elsewhere for a publisher to be
okay with that
um
for a publisher to be like it's like a
give and take of like okay if you keep
making
bucket loads of cash off of shot cards
you can make gta 6.
keep that up and you can make this it's
like a give and take situation so
the rockstar licensing here um
literally
actually sounds like an incredible deal
for remedy i think that they even get
royalty opportunities which is
incredible rockstar's paying for it
remedy i'm making it
and
i get that technically means to take
two's paying for it
um probably i haven't read the fine
print on that i imagine that that's how
that has to work like structurally
um
but in any case the the things that
people don't like about rockstar i think
are from the publisher end and not from
the rockstar in-house
uh end in terms of the way that they
actually develop games again the
trilogy re-release remaster whatever was
not actually made
by rockstar
so remedy is making this remedy are
gonna make it the way remedy do be
making things i think they have a pretty
uh significant quality for all of their
releases rockstar has the license so
they own max payne which means that they
have to license remedy to do that um
that's what the relationship is and yeah
it seems like it does work really well
for remedy that they have a lot of
creative control from what i was reading
and they
have royalty opportunities too so
it'd be really good for remedy and i
don't imagine that
i i just don't think that any concerns
about the quality because of association
with rockstar are founded when i feel
like things like shark cards the the
prevalence of constantly advertising gta
online is much more from
a take two standpoint than a rockstar
standpoint um and the reason that we
have to kind of put up with rockstar
doing things people don't like to be
fair not many of which have ever
bothered me all that much uh would have
loved that single player dlc for gta 5
but here we are
um is because
the next game they make will again be
one of the most expensive games ever
made and take two is a publisher that
likes money uh they own a lot of mobile
games they invested in
several model studios they had plans to
release like 300 games in a really small
span of time tank 2 isn't hiding what
their goals are they they they are a big
old business all publishers are but
take two's not they're not playing
around um
and
again those
you know
money-driven tactics i think are part of
why
we ultimately
get really good rockstar games red dead
redemption 2 was not that long ago it
seems too soon to write them off
um
so i just want to talk about that
because i feel like i've seen people
maybe misunderstand what licensing means
roxanna's not making it and roxanna
didn't make the gta trilogy so the last
one
is monkey island which oh my god like
blew my mind i was so shocked by this
news
uh from polygon
new monkey island game returned to
monkey island arriving in 2022 from
original creator ron gilbert that is so
nuts
that they pulled this off
and that it didn't leak apparently this
was years in the making
i don't know what disney's doing
somebody's dying for these things surely
um so i've actually not watched this
trailer
[Music]
it's pretty simple
[Music]
ron gilbert told me he'd never make
another monkey island unless
[Music]
very very very um
just for anyone who hasn't played monkey
island please find a way to so pivotal
to so many people the fact that it's
lucas as well
didn't see it coming very excited about
it um so this article says nearly 32
years since the release of the secret of
monkey island and over 13 years since
2009's tales of monkey island publisher
developer digital whom i love and
lucasfill games who are very excited
about the return of have announced the
release of return to monkey island the
game the new game is due later this year
he said if i ever get to make another
monkey island i'm going to announce it
on april 1st in 2013 and he did do that
that's so funny
um
the game will be developed by terrible
toy box who released the point-and-click
adventure game thimbleweed park in 2014.
i actually did play a tiny bit of that
game but never got super into it maybe i
should go back
serious composers michael land peter
mcconnell and clint budjakian will
return to compose the game's score
uh dominic armado who voiced the series
protagonist guy brush in every monkey
alley game to date will return to
replace his role as the iconic character
this is just super exciting like just so
unexpected i don't have any tidbits to
add other than i was like oh my god i
didn't see that coming
and again i just feel like kind of feeds
into the
not needing e3 thing they announced that
on april fool's day
how cool just a very exciting one
especially when you see like
it's the original creator it's not some
kind of cash grab that somebody else
took because they had the license it's
the original creator coming back with uh
basically the original team
that's the kind of like
ip return that you want i think it's
just so neat i'm so stoked about it
monkey island's incredible um
yeah so that is pretty much it i just
wanted to talk about some of the news
that came out this week
just wanted to talk about it there's no
play watch listen this week so
i just i'm just talking at you you know
feeling good about it sometimes you just
gotta sit down talk about some video
games
life's good
i don't know i hope you guys enjoyed
this video i'll see you next time